de bayonne d'ajaccio de la cei de bach
dilatoire du havre soixante groupes près
de 800 danseurs avec pour seul objectif
se qualifie pour la finale et gagner
leur billet d'entrée pour les états unis
pour les championnats du monde
alors que les qualifiés se concentrent
en backstage dans la salle c'est le show
entre les supporters et les spectateurs
orléanaise
c'est aussi pour ça que la finale est
organisée à orléans pour l'ambiance et
la bonne ambiance c'est la ville en fête
ou personnes - jusqu'à mon premier pas
personal à chaque fois je regarde les
ans l'ambiance est tellement forte pour
les groupes qualifiés pour la finale
c'est le résultat de toute une année de
travail tous sont et par un jury de
professionnels sur différents critères
la performance et la technique donc moi
j'ai déjà performance en fait pour
simplifier ans dans cette ancienne
médina partie stick note technique pour
le patinage ou com
comme les danses de salon et donc moi je
regarde tout ce qui est costumes tout ce
qui est expression scénique puisqu'ils
et si un message qui est derrière
derrière la performance je regarde les
costumes je regarde le sourire donc je
regarde toutes les enveloppes
on va virer
qui artistique et si l'afrique
et aussi d autant dire que noté est
difficile car le nouveau et de plus
accusé grues et de résultats serrés
c'est pas mieux
l'énergie dégagée en voit et on va
tomber la polygamie en fait qui nous est
vraiment la place vous allez là-bas à
phoenix et qui est made des
qualifications en finale c'est monter
ses montées nous avons fait plaisir
c'est vraiment une fierté de les voir
être une voix me donne et ils sont
vraiment à l'essai du travail prochain
[Musique]
la différence c'est le public qui
l'appelle ici qu'importe la concurrence
les meilleurs ont droit à leur standing
[Applaudissements]